[Musique]
par les enfants bon choix au patron ce
que je suis content ce que je suis
content d'avoir retrouvé mes petits amis
et comment te sens-tu ce soir nos super
patron je suis guéri je te sens chute du
colloque propre nom le seul
bob popopopop
oro
oui on va tellement gathegi repartira
ce que j'ai entendu on veut me gratter
[Musique]
mais nous ça va très bien je suis guéri
ah c'est toi ne m'en
lalo
mois
et alors
bongo oui ou non tiens un patient je
meurs de faim mais j'ai pas mangé
cuillère
donné l'émoi ses langues de chat que
vous m'avez préparer
[Musique]
ce qu'au second
ce coffret bon
c'est tout non on va importe de faire un
beau cadeau oui j'suis pas
celle que tu aimes le plus salée pour
toi le plus cool
et voilà du tabac dans une belle boîte
des quotas oui ce que je suis gratuit
l'appel tabatière et tu peux fumer toi
tu es grand vieille école à on va se
coucher
au tabac tu veux ça lui a fait plaisir
que t'as pas moi je comprends sa merci
mais chers petits vous m'avez gratter
gothic 4 à 10 ans vous êtes trop gentil
je remonte vite montré ses beaux cadeaux
aux marchands de sable boni
le petit
beaune une annonce à gamin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nos sources tu es petit ami ton
fait des cadeaux oui patron mais ce
n'est propos ou à
[Musique]
g du monde
amateur et du bon tabac dans nos tentes
et du phare tu viendras taper mais ce
n'est pas
fait du bon tabac dans ma tabatière fait
du bon tabac mais non dans
[Musique]
j'ai du bon tabac pour hépatites j'ai du
bon tabac tue nos enfants dans les blanc
et noirs
c'est dans d'autres cas les soldes c'est
du bon tabac
[Musique]
e
je comprends bien nounours je ne suis
pas ton ami mon petit patron seulement
dans la chanson vous voulez du tabac
mais tu sais bien que je ne fume pas ne
noces le moineau plus pop au en route
bonne nuit les enfants de pur
[Musique]
voir mes petits amis
n'ayez pas peur c'est le tonnerre et
nous sommes
qu'est ce que vous dit pas trop pour nos
taux vient
[Musique]
je dit il y à du tonnerre
eu rien entendu nous je dis qu'il ya du
toner
[Musique]
j'espère que tu n'as pas peur aux bras
sa main
[Musique]
ont des paiements toi
qui est si bas
ouais ne restez pas près de la fenêtre
les enfants c'est là tout près en europe
najet ben laden on nous regarde la chose
toi d'être dans le ciel je suis athée
c'est clair
[Musique]
je n'ai pas papa papa
là
ce n'est prof pas vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette année nous fermer ce petit feu
cette fenêtre ou où je me
demande pas trop ce soir je dors issue
ouf il était il de te
ils étaient tous
je n'arrive pas trop
un petit verdot et j'arrive
merci l'epa peut
à tout moment
venu nicolas et pimprenelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà l'orage est terminée nounours
est vraiment un gros nigo qu'en
pensez-vous les enfants ou où on y va
papa papa pas trop en route mon bon
nounours bonne nuit les petits allez
sagement vous coucher est fait de deux
bouts bonbons pour
les enfants
[Musique]
[Rires]
bravo nounours patron la musique chasse
le mauvais temps y apporte la bonne
humeur et nounours descend chez ses amis
pour l'échelle hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop
bord les petits
tu va nous aider chute alors nous allons
faire un nouveau jeu non nous préparons
surprise
ou
c'est un secret et c'est une surprise tu
verra demain c'est une très grande
surprise et dites moi
je l'aude
[Musique]
ou travaux
c'est la tête de con à temps
quand je l'entends je suis content
c'est la fête on va s'amuser
non cela nous accompagner mme montour ce
qui est le plus joli manège remonter sur
les chevaux de bois
on ira jouer aux anneaux
on regardera le zoo dont
on rencontrera des amis
qui ça me rende aussi nous nous fierons
chercher le comble c'est que nous
devions sierra hd une gamme
à projan sera fatigué
fera se reposent les
jeunes apprennent la dînette
on ya vitesse coucher
[Applaudissements]
dit tu nous emmènera vraiment un jour
sur le manège j'ai reçu et bien tout est
prêt on n'attend plus que la surprise
moi en orientant qui pousse ne serait
plus une surprise à liliane et que la
voilà
qu'est ce que ça peut bien
[Musique]
bonne nuit petit cachottier
la jette un liner
à deux bouts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
vos nuits les enfants
alors nounours patron de hma nous aurons
une grande surprise
vous ne savez pas ce que ce barrage ah
non
allons gros un patient en route route
fait pour
[Musique]
mon le choc bonsoir les enfants on n'est
que tu es pressé et nounours mais petit
jamie mon feuilles sur twizz patrons y
en a de la chance aux sahraouis le cher
et bien c'est tout ce désordre ma
surprise
[Musique]
mais qui est
des chaussettes une chemise
une salopette
mais oui ça y est ça
s'accorde huchon
mon petit cornichons quelle surprise
mais comment es tu venu ici et là c'est
parano admis avec ta dah oui avec dead
evans de la même remarcher ils
laissaient un passage ça alors vous en
avez de la chance mais bien cornichons
nous allons aider à faire ton lit au
nous veut poli il aime pas les fils m
couché par terre il a apporté tout son
matériel de camping tout mon matériel
cher cornichons tu dormiras prêtres dans
la champ
voilà comme ça voilà là
[Musique]
l'une paillasse c'est ce qu'il ya de
meilleur et de meilleure
animation
picquenot fera partie mais gérard
collomb
alors que ce que j'entends
il n'est pas question de jouer quand je
serais parti
on a bien transfert
compris nicolas bien sûr mon nounours
bon mais toi aussi cornichons tu as
compris
[Musique]
oui
oui je dors mois dans la salle de bain
tu dors dans la salle de bains nounours
c'est pour avoir de l'eau fraîche quand
j'ai soif
la
corniche au salut
salut
le petit salé n'annonce
pas une école à salé pas prendre mal
faite pour rêve
[Musique]
ô
bonne surprise c'est une surprise
cornichons est arrivé patron pimprenelle
et nicolas doivent être contents oh oui
revis rampi est bien en route bonne nuit
des enfants embrasser bien fort vos
parents une photo pour eux
salut
on
sera les enfants bon faut un patron il
me tarde de savoir comment notre petits
cornichons a passé la journée et bien et
sent vite mon gros nounours sitôt dit
sitôt fait ma petit déjeune
à tout de suite à tron
[Musique]
savait que je
salue il prépare son petit déjeuner pour
demain matin c'est de la fois oui
l'avoine comme dada et du miel comme
nounours à tartines j'aime pas les
tartines moi le matin je mange toujours
dans ma toupine mais vous savez que de
la voix mais du miel ce doit être sue
culot
tient gouttes nounours
[Musique]
ce vraiment en pot on dirait les
recettes de ma soeur emilie à
chérie
je vais t'aider cornichons ouais
j'aime mieux préparer mon petit déjeuner
tout seul
on lave t'as pas tout nous donne moi ma
quille bon
aux
cornichons tu es venu
[Musique]
lors du show tu vas t'en rue mais
t'inquiète pas dans la forêt je suis
toujours pieds nus noisy à la classe
mais ça me toujours pieds nus s'est
amusé à mettre un pied ni et bien il est
l'heure d'aller au lit à présent
cornichons penta salle de bain nicolas
et pimprenelle je vous accompagne
salut salut
et de brun vous aiderez votre ami
corniche on a retrouvé ses souliers il a
déjà mis de l'ordre aujourd'hui on
s'amuse bien avec lui et qui sait ce que
nicole avena 9 n'ont quà la
[Musique]
commission dalo en dormez-vous vite que
toi aussi
où est-il pas sûr
cornichons
et d'un mois
hossa alors ce soir tu dors dans la
cuisine avec ta toupine on sait jamais
s'il y avait des souris
bonne nuit corniche au salut
salut
salut les p'tits
mecs bourrés
[Musique]
alors nounours tout va bien à merveille
patron et vous savez cornichons fait de
la très bonne cuisine de très
intelligent ce petit gros gourmand va
allons en route bonne nuit les enfants
fait beau rêve salut
par les enfants bonsoir
patron je suis très anciens et que vous
bien sûr que nous sommes au-dessus de la
maison de nicolas et d'autres repreneurs
mais oui nounours nous y sommes je vous
crois bon jeu votre
propre patron oui vous n'auriez pas
lampe de poche
tient à north tu ne vas pas me dire que
tu as peur non mais il fait très sombre
ce soir trains sont
au point
mort
[Musique]
mais il fait tout noir là dedans y'a
personne
nicolas
un preneur
en quarts un tel régime il est très tôt
mais cornichons il nous a dit de dormir
tôt car demain on se lève à 6h du matin
1 600 wii pour aller cueillir des
champignons
il n'y a pas de champignons ici il va
nous emmener très loin
avec ses parents au avec data vous lui
ferez toutes mes amitiés
je vous laisse dormir
et cornichons il est dans la cuisine je
vais lui dire bonsoir
[Musique]
mais il n'est pas dans la cuisine
cornichons où es tu oui celui-là comment
tu es dehors
je dors à la belle aux labels à la belle
étoile nourris
sur le balcon au bon pourquoi pas à la
belle de nuit quand les shows salut ça
les grands méchants salut de noces
[Musique]
je viens voilà tu cherche quelque chose
vient de coucher nicolas
[Musique]
les enfants vous ne savez pas cornichons
cache la toupine avec son petit déjeuner
ne fait pas tant de bruit tu la
trouveras pas onze comme ils ont la
tâche et elle est tellement bien caché
que personne ne la trouvera
c'est comme ces souliers puiqu'il les
arranger on le retrouve bleus elle va à
chienne une aile veinards est bien de
même temps vous les trouverez il ne faut
pas qu'il sorte piennes il pourrait se
faire mal et puisque vous vous lever tôt
en dormez-vous vite
bonheur ça lui fait de boer
mon
[Musique]
ennui les enfants patrons qu stock
ressemble d'être un l'apple à la belle
ola plutôt rural voulons c'est vrai le
ciel et pau ce soir et des étoiles
brillent allons en route bonnut des
enfants faites de beaux rêves
salut
[Musique]
savoir les enfants ont froid j'espère
que mes petits amis on ramassait
beaucoup de champignons aujourd'hui dans
les bois
[Musique]
alors je n'en mangerai pas patron je
vous le promets
ou
montluel et hop
[Musique]
mais que tu poulenc risque à les pendre
dans les lisières monde est un petit coq
l'enfant mange tout chaud ils étaient
tous là blanche qu à les pondre un la
grange odette un petit goût que l'enfant
mange tous au l'été pull noir qu à les
pondre dans la presse on est un pic aux
colons font manger
touché l'été tout le bruit qu'elle parle
d'un ali lunettes rondes est ainsi
qu'aux pour l'enfant qui peut
nono
ce qu'elle est jolie cette chanson
mais ça ne m'étonne pas vous avez fait
une grande promenade
aujourd'hui on a ramassé beaucoup de
champignons armé choo par michaud dans
les champignons et de nous oui
tiens tiens c'est pour toi tu pourrais
le faire une omelette ou oui une
omelette aux champignons
merci lezons font un cornichon tu es
toujours pieds lui
plaisait pas retrouvé mes souliers nous
je crois qu'il faut que je me force
à nous jouer de la guitare vient nous
[Musique]
bien tu sais je cornichons ouais
voilà
[Musique]
salut
ou
oui
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ne nous
[Musique]
retournons vite à la maison pas trop
nous allons faire une bonne petite au
bloc aux cheminots oh oh oh oui tu la
mangera demain car ce soir tu tombe de
sommeil allons en route bonne nuit les
enfants allez vite vous couchez vous
aussi haut
bonsoir mes petits amis
j'espère que vous avez été sages l'ont
été patron j'en suis certain mais ses
cornichons qui me donne bien du souci il
dort n'importe où pourvu qu'il n'est pas
couché à l'appel et toi courage nounours
descend vite ou le seul
propos
méchants oui
et puis des bûches
[Musique]
ça va être formidable
presque comme dans la forêt bonsoir les
enfants
salut
volontiers au travail long museau
au shoot l'arôme du rosier d'accord je
connais pas je vous écoute comme ça tu
pourra la prendre
que voilà la
mort en juin quatre fers au velours
aussi à quatre fleurs d'une chambre
haute en couleurs quant à lui est arrivé
bon je peux le rouge encore elle y est
d'arriver meilleur faire monde avait
[Musique]
fini 4e commission non 4 champignons
nous notre boutures ont
même mois et les haies messieurs le
bouton de rose dans ce tous les cadres
entre eux à hydro merveilleux quand le
soleil est levé
motorola
plan fusionner dans l'art osé porter le
voile à bord bouger pour le retour le
journal
[Musique]
merci maman tu nous as beau
j'aimerais quand même savoir ce que vous
préparez vous rien dire c'est une
surprise
demain soir
une fête qui verra vous êtes gentils les
petits mais ne fait pas de bêtise et toi
corniche on retrouve des souliers
t'inquiète pas mon gros nounours allons
nicolas et pimprenelle oui il est à
[Musique]
c'est une belle surprise comme près par
la dass c'est très gentil suis sûr que
ça plaira là j'ai pas lu ne
demain
cornichons tué dans la salle de bain
nous j'ai près de la cheminée
surveille le bois pour koné sipa bonne
nuit mon petit corniche aux salles une
ourse
fait beau rêve
[Musique]
pas trop il me prépare une nouvelle
surprise le cher petit j'ai hâte d'être
à demain en route mon bon nounours allez
vite vous coucher les enfants n'oubliez
pas de faire votre toilette de bien vous
laver les dents et fait bourrer
des enfants bonsoir
quelle drôle d'odeur et de la fumée
patron mon casque de pompier et mon
échelle de pompiers
propos pompe au pot à son honneur
athènes un peu de fumée et le voilà qui
s'affolent change les marchands c'est
marrant
au pot pour les pompiers arrivent ou elf
ou
toute cette fumée à un moment il y avait
des flammes fomina howie comme dans la
forêt comme quand on fait un feu de camp
mais à présent il ya des marrons chauds
c'est pour l'anniversaire tu es ma
poupée john mchugh
[Musique]
alors mademoiselle caprices venez me
soucier vos bougies
et voile manchots
[Musique]
bonne anniversaire
ma poupée joli mais oui ma chère c'est à
fait aujourd'hui
tarab et nouvelle tout en organdi
qui est bien belle
avec des broderies
la poupée chérie ma poupée chez rue
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut chanter
moi je vais vous apprendre une belle
chanson écoutée
tralalala la halle où la liberté à lui
la liberté
[Musique]
des
hommes se saluent je reviendrai jouer
demain voilà patron sera vu sa vue
[Musique]
du calme les enfants il est l'heure de
dormir à présent alou pas nous alloue un
loup la liberté où la liberté
devient bien turbulent nos enfants pas
trop ce qu'on c'est abusé ce qu on leur
y propose ce qu'on avait pourtant mieux
mais il faut être raisonnable et des
enfants doivent dormir cheuvreux bulle
en
haut en route aux hutus bonne nuit
faites de beaux rêves faute de boer
à nous pas loupé à l'eau pas de bol
visiteurs t on au libor
bonsoir les enfants notre nounours est
très gai ce soir je descends jouer
patron et ce soir c'est moi qui ai
préparé une surprise à l'intention de
mes amis amuse-toi bien mais ne fait pas
trop le fou mon école et hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
beaucoup
saluent les enfants
[Musique]
sur les partis
il a oublié ses souliers on vient de les
retrouver allons ne soyez pas triste il
reviendra à votre ami cornichons
vous voyez mais j'ai une belle surprise
pour vous si jani khel
une jolie histoire que je vais vous
raconter
voilà mon histoire se passe dans les
pays bas pourquoi les pays bas n'ont ce
qu'est ce que ça
les piles bras c'est un pays où la mer
est plus haute que la terre
[Musique]
mais les habitants ont construit de
grande digue qui empêche la mer d'entrer
dans les terres
les hollandais ils sont très courageux
écouter la suite de l'histoire
il ya très longtemps
j'ai eu une tempête terrible tout près
de la digue il y avait une jolie petite
maison dans laquelle vivait à papa une
maman et leur tt ça qui sait le fleuve
qui se jette dans la mer il y avait non
une très grosse trentaine et le vent se
fait très très fort il jetait les vab
contre l'as dit
mais le bébé dormait tranquillement et
seul le chat de la baie vous avec
rapport les mains ils étaient sortir
au moment de faire ses commissions et le
papa à son travail et tout à coup
la mer grâce elle a dit qu il vend des
normes 20 litres est dans le flou il
s'est tellement d'aplomb
le feu aux portes de
quelle catastrophe
le long de moi le vent ne souffle plus
la tempête avaient cessé mais la jolie
petite maison avait disparu
mais à la surface de l'eau quelque chose
bougeait c'était un chat qui se trouvait
sur un perso emploi qui se balançaient
au gré des rares et libye le chat
l'avait sauvé car ils avaient peur de
l'eau les chats et à chaque fois qu'une
vague allaient pénétrer dans le berceau
ils sont 1 de l'autre côté pour ne pas
se faire mouiller
ils ne se rendaient compte de rien car
il dormait le chérubin lara ils
cherchaient leurs enfants avec une
barque il était très inquiet quand tout
à coup il est arrivé à sa main oui vite
ils se sont approchés ils ont retrouvé
leurs enfants qui dorment toujours
[Musique]
les hollandais ont reconstruit leurs
dégâts encore plus solide
et les parents leur maison encore plus
jolie qu'avant la tempe heures ça ils
l'ont beaucoup gratter et le bébé a
grandi en sa compagnie et on a faim son
meilleur ami
était très jolie cette histoire merci 90
voilà pas trop à vue
nous allons nous coucher tout seul bonne
nuit nenov bonne nuit les petits
[Musique]
où
oui
[Musique]
cornichons est reparti avec ses parents
mais il reviendra bientôt voir nicolas
et pimprenelle il reviendra patron il
reviendra à rod nounours bon et nuit
fait pour eux
[Musique]